aimer la plaque et a aidé à hussein ont
généré 1,5 kw est nommé au premier
j'étais ravie parce qu'on m'avait flux
en baisse comme je dis comme la rép
et puis on m'a ressuscité ensuite je me
suis tapé dessin mais pratiquement on a
vécu beaucoup plus à tourner les
angéliques à vivre dans la vie pour
ouais ouais ça a pris cinq ans je crois
alors on continue avec les femmes robert
hossein parce qu'en 60 est vous avez une
aventure du peu tragique avec michel we
m'est arrivé c'est diane mouss ces gens
parlent très peu de progrès
je vois rien c'était la comédie
française vous répéter et à nani et puis
je suis allée marié et tous mes copains
attendait sur la côte et c'était une
jeune femme tout à fait est rare tout à
fait sympathique généreuse et du bel et
et le jour du mariage m cet accident de
voiture où elle conduisait et on avait
une loi qu'il demandait pour mettre des
ceintures a ajouté je crois mais moi je
vais pas me la mienne vous ce que vous
aimez pas l'ami la sienne il ya eu un
accident et elle a trouvé la mort une
manière assez effrayant êtes un petit
signe dans le feu je ne sais pas si vous
savez on interprète
toujours est il que et vous vous êtes
rester par terre après l'accident avec
une fracture de la colonne vertébrale et
bien des années plus tard au moment où
vous êtes directeur artistique du
théâtre de paris vous avez à l'intérieur
du théâtre un appartement et un jour cet
appartement vous habitez à l'époque avec
candice patou votre votre femme brûle
entièrement mais et vous vous retrouvez
dans l'appartement que la bague que vous
portiez vous aviez la même avec michel
toutes avaient flambé
il restait plus strictement rien du
studio mais rien tout était même les
costumes étaient restés sur les vins
tout était calciné complètement et
simplement le chef des pompiers maudite
neige vous rend la petite bague que j'ai
trouvée et que j'avais égaré depuis
du temps ce qui représentait deux mains
qui se tendaient il m'a rendu la
baguette pour voir votre deuxième épouse
officielle après marina vlady ça et et
caroline eliacheff la fille de françoise
giroud elle avait 16 ans et si j'allais
chercher ma femme à l'école j'étais un
peu traité de pédophile à l'époque en
même temps on dirait que vous aimez bien
les jeunes qui un jour par exemple ayvaz
dit non mais attendez vous faites
prendre l'avion à vadim vous repérer une
gonzesse de 15 ans sur la plage vous
faites prendre un avion à vadim et vous
avez été très sage est passé la journée
à regarder sur l'assaut du bateau et un
avec cette fille de 15 ans est reparti
le soir je dis pas qu'il se passait des
choses graves mais c'était quand même
incroyable la petite anna gras comme ça
je sais pas écoutez je deux choses
horribles qui paraît étrange bizarre ou
n'importe quoi il m'est arrivé des
choses tout à fait hallucinante mais je
trouve complètement naturel je veux dire
rien d'étonnant là dedans pour
maintenant vous êtes sages ça va qu'est
ce que vous appelez être sage et une
femme que j'aime beaucoup si j'allais
dire tu dois être présent avant candice
patou il savait depuis 76 maintenant
votre l'infirmière héroïque mirent à
laquelle a été tout à fait étonnant mais
je ne peux pas la suivre parce que tous
les matins se lèvent et elle commence à
faire 10 km en courant dans le box
boulogne c'est difficile à dire que vous
n'êtes pas les suivants mois